understand
no i'm not lying you're right i did cry
to you yeah because it was embarrassing
but i said deeps inside oh god
deeper deeper
yeah yeah yeah you're rejoicing there's
different levels and deep down inside
and it's still there it still makes me
laugh yeah i have so many of those i
have hundreds of those
of awkward moments that i in the middle
of the night i'm like
i have so many of those i i just and
there and for me they're not even off of
like you know doing the joke you
shouldn't do they're just off of you
know not recognizing someone fast enough
or calling someone by the wrong name or
you know and then then giving me [ __ ]
and i was like
yeah you know i think you had one of
those stories with judd i think you guys
went to like a benefit thing together
and then you got really sad seinfeld yes
no but that wasn't no that wasn't
because no but you came back really no
because
reveal it baby because um seinfeld's
wife yeah kept calling me billy no yeah
robbie or robbie yeah yeah she kept
calling me robbie and i think one point
i said it's bobby but she kept calling
me robbie
right it's kind of the same it is kind
of the same but i'm also with you yeah
yeah you mean and you're embarrassed
like that you didn't like know how to
correct it yeah in that sense
is it would
could you correct during that moment
because i would be too awkward i would
never correct anymore i let them go
i know but i don't think that's healthy
is that healthy i don't know if
someone's just like hey jebediah what
are you doing
i
i'm jebediah the rest of the day oh
really you know like people say like is
it apatow or apatow i'm like either way
is fancy i mean how i am i don't correct
people about my name anymore it's not
like it's whatever you need well your
name is kalaila it's hard it's hard but
that's what you're saying yeah
it's whatever you need it to be you know
what my thing is i like wouldn't say
your name out of fear
that i would mispronounce it and then as
a result of that i forget it
and i have that with like tons of people
where i'm afraid you know if it's like
is it kirsten or kristen and then i just
panic never say it and then at some
point i don't even know what it is yeah
i hate it when they're mad and you're
close
yeah so it's like hey christina it's
christine yeah how was i i met you one
time well robbie is close to bobby you
shouldn't have felt that didn't i didn't
lash out you well you came home crying
so much crying because i why is the
reaction because i internalize it right
because for me it's like you know as
a comedian and also you audition a lot
and you get a lot of rejection so you
teach your face
to not show pain
yeah right because it's like even on
stage you know this when the crowd just
no matter what you do they're just not
into it and you have and if you reacted
viscerally to
the response you would show it on your
face and they would make it worse
so for me as i've trained my face to
just be like i'm bombing
i'm robbing
like with what judges said like there
are times where i'll lay in bed and i'll
think of where i got booed off i got
booed off the stage in front of 20 000
people oh okay yeah you're mean i got
literally boosted what show was that the
issue of this show called the dog house
comedy
night
in san jose was at the amphitheater and
this is back in the early 2000s they had
like
chappelle mencia
pablo francisco i mean the lineups were
insane cat williams and
and i had to follow leslie jones